aujourd'hui je vous parle non connectés
ça fait quelques jours que j'ai au
poignet à cette petite montre c'est la
samsung galaxy watch active qui est
arrivé avec sa jolie petite boîte très
sympa bien que six autres actifs qui est
hyper intéressante parce que je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez les dernières sa
pelouse a présenté la galaxie moi je moi
j'ai adoré la galaxie watch j'étais
vraiment fan de cette petite molette qui
vous sert pour naviguer face à trouver
vraiment vraiment intéressante
là vous avez un autre modèle qui était
présenté en même temps que les samsung
galaxy s 10 et la molette n'est pas
présent sur ce produit bon c'est un
produit qui a eu la donne qui est
différente on va être sur un public un
peu plus mixte un peu moins typé
masculin donc qui conviendra aussi bien
aux hommes qu'aux femmes
une honte que je trouve très
intéressante que je vous présente les
pires je compte sur vous pour me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec boulanger
merci boulangers doivent en donner
l'occasion de tester la nouvelle samsung
galaxy watch active
première chose vous avez une boîte qui
est assez sympa bon c'est assez
minimaliste samsung galaxy watch active
il n'ya pas grand-chose de ouf et vous
montrez à l'intérieur regardez vous
retrouver ici
bon elle est déjà ouverte vous vous en
douterez si vous avez votre petit
recharge à induction une petite
recherche ce qui se fait de l'autre côté
en usb vous le brancher sur une prise
sur ce que vous voulez sur agrandi sa
surcharge
elle vient se plaquer directement la y
perd facilement aimante et ça tient bien
ses pratiques donc ça c'est assez cool
la montre dames aiment se trouve assez
sympa c'est très mixte en fait parce que
sont la galaxie watch son avis cette
grosse molette que moi j'adore
personnellement là du coup ici il n'y a
pas de grosse molette on a une monde qui
est beaucoup plus fils très élégante
pour venir changer votre bracelet si
vous voulez s'ils voulaient pas
forcément un bracelet de cette couleur
là ça devrait du silicone qui se
positionne assez facilement ce que je
vous conseille c'est de faire gaffe à
l'est pas trop le serré parce que on se
rend pas compte vous le sert et un petit
peu trop
et à force la journée aux usa savent ou
compriment un petit peu c'est pas c'est
pas génial en termes de confort lacéré
pas trop suffisamment pour qu'elle
marche mais que vous soyez pas
complètement écrasée moi je la sers pas
trop je l'aimé comme ça alors ça c'est
un truc que j'aime pas trop en fait sur
cette typologie de bracelets mais j'irai
même chose avec les appels watch c'est
que lorsque vous passez ce truc là quand
vous avez des poils et bien moment ça ça
vous tire un peu ça vous arrache un peu
les poils donc il faut trouver sa
position de confort et ensuite ça va oui
ça c'est un point de détail c'est assez
masculin mais voilà bon une fois qu'elle
est comme ça par contre on est vachement
bien on a vraiment faire un petit format
qui a ses couleurs vous avez deux
boutons sur le côté ici uniquement de
bouton en premier bouton qui vous
servira à l'allumer à l'activer à
l'éteindre et un deuxième bouton qui
vous servira à arriver à vos différentes
applications alors la grosse différence
c'est que ce que vous aviez notamment
sur la galaxie watch vous tourniez comme
ça s'était produit parce que vous avez
une navigation qui était hyper simple ça
c'est un peu frustrant c'est vraiment ce
qu'est ce qui m'a surpris au début aux
risques hamas en manque du coup et bien
vous venez avec vos doigts vous appuyez
dessus et vous arrivez up sur le bouton
ici pour changer de place changer de
quadrant après il faut venir appuyer
directement dessus pour les activer
alors bon on retrouve les fonctions
essentielles peuvent venir a ajouté
après des applications si vous souhaitez
vous avez votre galaxy store un qui se
trouve juste là vous avez bien
évidemment dans toutes les applications
que j'utilise et le téléphone les
contacts bixby ça me son aile ce qu'on
va retrouver également sur l'appli santé
qui est vachement intéressante je monte
ça juste après le catalogue samsung paye
vous pouvez payer effectivement avec ça
c'est aussi très intéressant tous vos
paramètres la météo vous arrivez ici
vous avez votre alarme votre calendrier
reminder les musiques la galerie spotify
afin voyez vous pourrez vous pouvez
installer plein plein de choses c'est
vraiment cool et dans les paramètres
vous pouvez venir régler pas mal de
choses alors c'est intéressant parce
qu'il tourne sous tyson 4.0.1 0.3 pour
une très précis mais également avec mon
oeil
on a plein de choses intéressantes vous
êtes plein d'infos vous pouvez me régler
facilement tous vos petits paramètres
bon je vous si ça vous intéresse vous ne
serez découvrir c'est très complet c'est
bien la navigation est vraiment simple
voyez l'écran est génial parce qu'il
fonctionne très très rapidement et
extrêmement réactif up même un peu trop
très très réactif donc ça c'est cool
vous n'êtes ni sans doute en haut vous
revenez à votre menu principal vous
rappeler encore vous revenir sur votre
écran d'accueil vous avez plusieurs
cadres en voulait s'appuyer là vous
pouvez venir choisir parmi plein de
cadran vous pouvez en télécharger
d'autres vous faites ce que vous voyez
le truc sont très très très masculin des
trucs aussi féminin il ya vraiment tous
moi personnellement j'ai mis celui là
hop voilà pourquoi ce un paquet planète
j'aime beaucoup ce serait sympa lorsque
vous allez venir swype est sur la droite
vous arrivez sur des petits widgets donc
là vous avez des infos sur les choses
des activités vous avez fait la journée
vous retrouver mon calcul raccourci
principaux l'activité sportive votre
niveau de stress pouvait dire respirer
battement de votre coeur ça ces petites
choses que j'ai à faire il faut que je
m'occupe de la tva
et lorsque vous revenez avant vous
arrivez sur vos notifications alors la
voyez au petit motif instagram le
saviez-vous et lorsque vous pousser vers
le haut up afssa les effacer sa personne
d'autre tout ça c'est cool autre chose
lorsque vous êtes ici ça votre écran
d'accueil hop vous descendez il à vous
arrivez à vos petits comment dire des
petits raccourcis pour venir vous mettre
en mode avion si par exemple vous prenez
l'avion sa part voir ça peut avoir un
sens vous avez si ça dépend de votre
écran d'accueil mois si j'en trouve le
nombre de pas je retrouve ma batterie
qui pour l'instant à 18%
moi ce que je trouve vraiment bien avec
cette monde sait qu'elle va repérer
l'activité que vous faites l'autre jour
on est parti à l'île de ré pendant
quelques jours et à l'île de ré qu'est
ce qu'on fait on fait du vélo je vous le
donne dans le mille
et ce qui était vraiment cool c'est que
on se met sur le vélo on part aux
pédales et là tout de suite la montre
mais a reconnu l'activité et a lancé le
le compteur le chrono
sur l'activité des autres je trouve est
assez bluffé par ce que je dis comme ça
c'est vraiment cool parce que vous avez
commencé d'activité votre monde va tout
de suite repéré ce que vous allez faire
tout ça ça se fait par rapport à ces
différents capteurs elle est capable
d'analyser et de savants les activités
que vous allez faire lors le nombre de
pas c'est très facile elle un
accéléromètre un gyroscope et un
baromètre alain gps elle un capteur de
fréquence ladakh et avec tout ça elle
arrive à savoir ce que vous faites et
elles vous donnent des infos qui sont
fiables est vraiment intéressante et
comme je le disais elle fonctionne avec
l'application galaxy ace mais également
avec application galaxie où l adle sur
notre application galaxie ouvert et bol
vous allez retrouver toutes les
informations concernant votre montre
alors joie que je refusais une mise à
jour after frijoles que je la fasse les
infos de batteries ivresse 17% le temps
d'usagé de ma batterie le stockage
disponible sur les 4 gigas il reste un
point 5 gigas g2a que le syndicat
d'occuper et la ram disponible alors
j'ai pas configuré samsung paye mais je
peux le faire je vois que j'ai mise à
jour à faire sur le galaxy store je vois
mes applis que je peux utiliser
également que la montre après j'ai eu
notification les applications les
widgets le vibreur
moi j'ai plein de paramètres pour maman
qui situe directement dans s'applique
donc là c'est la partie je dirais plus
paramétrage de la bombe si je veux la
partie santé je vais dans samsung health
et là j'ai plein d'infos c'est vachement
intéressant parce que alors je vois les
papes que j'ai déjà effectué depuis ce
matin l'exercice marche donc il l'a
reconnu la marche tu peux démarrer
l'entraînement si je le nom de l'état
que j'ai commencé aujourd'hui
alors le sommeil ce n'est pas parce que
moi la nuit j'enlève ma montre mais vous
pouvez la garder pour dormir et y avoue
donnera plein d'informations sur votre
sommeil elle va choisir votre rythme
cardiaque après pouvez venir vous
paramétrez l'eau vous avez vu la caf et
initier sa bomba pouvait faire le niveau
de stress les différentes tendances de
stress en fonction des des jours dans
lequel vous étiez voyez moi j'ai pas
trop mal quand même là ça va c'était
hier il ya eu des moments c'était c'est
un peu la course là mais bon pour le
nombre d'étagés monté hier combien 11
étages sur les dix bravo et les
différents exercices assez intéressant
parce que comme je l ai dit je vais
reprendre le vélo savard connu vraiment
le vélo à l'île de ré voyez par exemple
le 22
j'ai fait trois heures et demie de vélo
en cette session donc ça c'est cool
parce que ça le reconnaît directement ça
vous donne les horaires ça c'est l'heure
à laquelle on a revu les vélos de
location tout cas prêt pouvait venir
calibré choisir en fonction de ce que
vous allez faire comme activité je sais
pas s'il va tout reconnaître type le
baseball pourquoi pas le basket
en tout cas vous pouvez venir vous le
calibre et dire voilà je fais cet
entraînement la boxe par exemple je vais
là débute
et à telle heure j'arrête à telle heure
si vous faites un entraînement de base
doit venir le démarré il ya pas mal de
possibilités pour un suivi de sportifs
je trouve que ça ses couleurs vous
retrouve également avec la galaxie wells
ça c'est pas tout nouveau là dessus mais
une fois de plus c'est là et font ça
plutôt bien pour le côté un peu
technique c'est un écran amoled c'est à
l'écran de 1,1 pouces de diagonale vous
avez une résolution de 360 par 360 fixé
à 463 ppp elle est assez léger elle fait
25 g toute la structure est en aluminium
elle tourne avec un exil aux 9110 elle a
4 gigas de stockage ça je voulais déjà
dit elle est compatible android mais
également un os
elle a une batterie de 230 millions
terreur moi je la garde de jour en
moyenne
j'ai pu la garder un peu plus là je suis
dans ma la 3e journée mais deux jours
c'est son cycle de vie normale elle est
bien évidemment aidant je pouvais
prendre votre douche pouvez vous l'avez
l étendre jusqu à 5 atm
moi je la trouve assez lumineuse lorsque
vous la mettez en plein soleil j'ai pas
eu de souci je trouve que l'écran est
assez lumineux c'est c'est plutôt bien
petite astuce pour venir l'état vous
couvrez avec la paume de votre main hop
elle est éteinte
en plus je trouve assez bien positionné
par rapport aux prix elle coûte 249
euros
elle et 80 euros moins cher que la
galaxie web qui coûte 3 129 euros bon ça
doit alors c'est vrai que moi
personnellement si je voulais aller sur
une monde connecté si j'avais 329 euros
je préférerais aller sur la galaxie
watch je la trouve plus typé masculine
que celle-ci jeu là j'aime bien le la
baule est néanmoins celle là ce qui me
plaît beaucoup c'est son côté discret
elle est vraiment discrète elle est très
citadine elle va à tout le monde aussi
bien aux hommes qu'aux femmes
vous pourrez faire la distinction avec
le bracelet en changeant je trouve que
l'écran est bien la qualité est là on a
une montre qui est très pratique qui
fonctionne bien et pour les sportifs
franchement je trouve vraiment très très
bien je sais pas comment vous la trouvez
ce que vous en pensez vous est-ce que
vous avez une monde connecté si oui
laquelle est ce que vous utilisez jeune
élite a marqué tout ça en bas ici en
dessous en commentaire dites moi ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que pourrait vous intéresser
d'ailleurs ce qu'elle vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien en bas pour la
trouver chez boulanger à tarif qui est
très intéressant sur ce je vous embrasse
je vous donne rendez vous dès demain et
d'ici là prenez soin de vous ciao